Art guys, so here's the example for the original block trading strategy. So we had this sweep, right, and then we had a change of character or market structure shift, whatever you want to call it. And then you had this, a lot of block right around here, and some imbalance around here. Right. So usually in this case, I would just mark out of the
this candle as well. And as you can see when price reacted from this level, it
created an impulsive move and left imbalance and auto block just as I explained.
So you want to take your entry from here. There you go. I want to put your stop
up there and that was a beautiful trade. There you go, you're 10 risk reward trade right here.
Very simple guys. So this is basically it guys. You just want to, if you want a confirmation entry.
Now most of the time you might miss out the trade, okay? Just because you didn't confirm it.
But the thing is that with confirmation entries, your win rate is gonna increase dramatically.
All right?
So I would say just go with this.
I mean, there are so many strategies that I have uploaded.
You only need to master one of those.
Okay?
You don't want to master each and every trading strategy.
Just find one, just choose one trading strategy and stick to it.
just keep on backtesting it, okay?
Just build that confidence.
That's pretty much it for this training strategy.
As you can see, I want to show you more examples,
but I really wanna move to the ABCD strategy
because it is a great one as well.
And this one is relatively, I hope you're clear by now.
I don't think you want more examples.
It's just that you just wanna see a reaction
from that auto block or fair value gap,
that creates the simple same move,
creates fair value gap, and then you take your entry
from here, that's pretty much it.
So I do hope that you liked this strategy as well,
it's a very good one.
So yeah guys, see ya.